I'm going to assume you're like me 50+
do you feel our age group and older
the 50+ woman is catered for in the Australian fashion industry
I actually do
yeah I do I think we've come a long way
I think there's a long way to go
we've talked about that
um there's more brands now advertising with women over 50
which you know
five years ago
you never saw that
they were trying to sell us clothes that they were putting on 20 year olds
yeah so I feel like it has come a long way
but it's got a way to go as well yeah
I think I agree
but I think um
obviously it's assumed that at our age
we're in a price bracket where we can afford to purchase
you know more expensive items
which is true
we have probably more disposable income than the younger ones
um but I think the industry needs to be very careful about
how much it increases its prices because even for us
some brands are lifting that price point to point where you like look
it's just either not worth it or it's just that bit too expensive for that
you know easy purchase
so that's all I'd say is yeah
is we will spend
we do spend we're not yet motivated by a sale
if I like it I'll buy it
but I also don't want to feel as though
you know it's too
it's I'm being a bit ripped off
to be honest
so interesting yeah
thank you very much
nice to meet you
likewise yeah